[Música]
[Aplausos]
llegaron unos antifaces en la entrada
por favor si tienen lentes se levantan
que sacar con lo que se los suavemente
el que no tenga antifaces apoya las
palmas de sus manos sobre los ojos
cada dos palmas sobre los ojos cierran
los ojos si tienen los antifaces
cierren los ojos me van a seguir con
unas respiraciones vamos a hacer
respiraciones empecemos 1
más aire 7
momento del aire que puedan
y larga lo suavemente
en frente de ustedes
no está la pantalla
tienen un color traten de percibir cuál
es el color que tienen enfrente es claro
si es oscuro y se les aparece un objeto
que les identifique cuál es el color que
tienen adelante
perfecto hasta que los antifaces
que levante la mano quien vio colores de
la línea del rojo
que mío colores la línea del azul
y colores de la línea declaró o del
amarillo
miren alrededor
éste se coló que estaba la pantalla
sí
vengo a contarles que como muchos de
ustedes yo pensaba que se ponía unos
antifaces y me tapaba los ojos no me ven
daban no podría ver si sufría algún tipo
de discapacidad visual o enfermedad y
perdía mi vista iba a quedar ciego o
discapacitado visual para siempre pero
resulta que existe en el mundo una
técnica que nos permite ver sin utilizar
los ojos que despierta una capacidad que
todos tenemos y lo voy a repetir durante
toda la charla que todos tenemos que nos
permite ver sin utilizar los ojos ahora
voy a mostrar un pequeño vídeo como para
que ustedes vayan abriendo un poquitito
la mente y entendiendo qué es esto de
ver sin utilizar los ojos
ah
[Música]
al escoger
y también personas que están manejando
un jardín
persona que cuando a los videojuegos
están utilizando unas antifaces
especiales que se llaman minds unos
antifaces que hay que mandarlos a pedido
del exterior que bloquean por completo
la vista depende el lugar del mundo ese
tipo de antifaz que se utiliza es lo que
están viendo es aaron face él es el
segundo presidente de la asociación de
ciegos y discapacitados visuales de
alemania él se conoció hace 15 años hace
5 aprendió un método y si lo que están
viendo es un sigo jugando al pool
cuando vi este método y lo conocí me
pareció increíble yo estaba buscando
cómo mejorar mi salud en realidad cómo
llegar a anciano con la misma energía
que tienen los 25 en esa búsqueda me di
cuenta que los alimentos eran la base de
nuestra nutrición diaria nuestra energía
diaria pero también me daba cuenta que
habían otras cosas y era la forma de
pensar llega el punto de mandar importar
un microscopio de campo oscuro que me
permitía hacer análisis de sangre en
tiempo real yo sacaba una gotita de
sangre y podía verla en tiempo real
podía ver cómo actuaban glóbulos blancos
glóbulos rojos como estaba el plasma
sanguíneo en ese momento en tiempo real
hice un curso directo en españa desde
internet para poder aprender a manejar
el aparato
el problema que me tenía que sacar una
gotita de sangre para poder hacer una
muestra y me hacía 20 por día llega el
punto que no podía doblar las manos del
dolor que tenía por la cantidad de veces
que me pinchaba el tema es que en las
muestras me daba cuenta que sí utilizaba
una meditación consciente antes de hacer
la muestra la sangre sería distinta así
es como se ve la sangre el microscopio
de campos q lo puede ver los glóbulos
blancos y los glóbulos rojos es también
un glóbulo blanco totalmente inmóvil de
un lado de un glóbulo blanco en
movimiento
realizando el trabajo que tiene que
hacer limpiando el plasma de la sangre
si bien esto no es una prueba científica
ni sirve para nada a mí me sirvió para
poder entender que el pensamiento
influye muchísimo en nuestro cuerpo
entonces me metí de lleno en el cerebro
en cómo podía mejorar mis pensamientos
cómo podía adquirir nuevas habilidades y
así es como me encuentro con este método
la capacidad de poder ver sin utilizar
los ojos ver a gente totalmente vendada
ciegos adultos chicos jugando al ajedrez
al fútbol
compitiendo carreras tío el blanco
la primera chava que veo es de katrina
métodos mentales escuelas rusas se
llamaba ella en la mitad de la charla se
pone unas gafas y empieza a leer un
cuento de edgar allan poe no pudo creer
si esto fuese cierto tenía que estar en
todos los diarios en las noticias en la
televisión
a medida que investigaba me da cuenta
que en muchos lugares del mundo existía
este método pero el tema era que todos
tienen un nombre distinto no era tan
fácil encontrarlos pero todos decían lo
mismo todos podemos desarrollar esta
capacidad los chicos lo adquieren de
forma natural los adultos les lleva
mucho más tiempo un chico de 6 a 12 años
pueda cree esta capacidad rápidamente un
adulto puede tardar meses o incluso años
un ciego discapacitado visual puede
estar años para poder adquirir esa
capacidad pero a todos les pasa lo mismo
obtiene una mejora en el nivel de la
salud y eso puede llegar a ser
simplemente por la meditación la
meditación ya hay miles de estudios que
nos muestran que nos dan una mejora de
la salud increíble pero no era solamente
en la salud depresión y ansiedad
desaparecían por completo los chicos con
muchos trastornos que tienen hoy en día
en muy pocas clases cambiaban por
completo uno de los lugares en donde
inicia esto es en indonesia y quizás
antes pero la parte de la información
que yo que vas a encontrar inicia ahí en
el mar para ti
miembros del mercader y que están en
indonesia podemos encontrar muchos
vídeos de militares practicando tiro al
blanco totalmente vendados
[Música]
totalmente vendados ellos se utilizan
cuatro tipos de vendas y encima una
bolsa en la cabeza
levante la mano y esa animaría a ponerse
un globo en la cabeza o en la boca con
alguien en frente o totalmente endo
practicando tiro blanco nadie
le ponemos a la gente de vibra visión
eso están en eeuu hasta ellos y fueron
los chicos que vieron manejando karting
o con las espadas al estilo star wars y
después vemos a la gente de info visión
que la gente posición lo que está en
eeuu y está en alemania y ellos en
cambio hicieron olimpiadas trabajan con
los chicos y los adultos todos vendados
jugando distinto tipo de juegos pero la
gente de información en cambio se juntó
con médicos y trataron de comprobar que
parte de nuestra cosa en la que realiza
esto si bien se sabe que es el
hipotálamo en conjunto con el hipocampo
y la glándula pineal se crean nuevas
redes neuronales que permiten ver sin
utilizar los ojos ver a través de unas
gafas sin utilizar los ojos una de las
cosas más increíbles es que pueden ver
que después de activar esta capacidad
las personas que sacan las gafas y se
mantienen estado meditación casi dos
horas después todos esos todo estos
estudios se están en internet y se
pueden ver después tenemos a la gente
divisiones calcular ellos son de méxico
la gente visión especular tiene un
método increíble que
trabaja con la familia en conjunto con
los chicos se trabajan con imágenes
psico dinámicas con las cuales uno en
estado de meditación profunda puede
saber cómo el chico está viendo a la
madre al padre a la familia a los amigos
al trabajo a la sociedad entonces nos
permite como vía para poder saber cómo
estamos educando a nuestro hijo si lo
estamos orientando bien o no si estamos
dando mucho amor o le está faltando si
le estamos dando muchos retos o le están
faltando retos una especie de guía y de
ayuda para poder educar a nuestro hijo
sin tener que esperar los 18 para que
nos demos cuenta como él percibe el
mundo
no tan sólo eso nosotros con mi hermano
somos instructores de este método y
viajamos para poder hacerlo después de
tres días de práctica nos tocan los
chicos cuando vienen los chicos elijo al
primero que tengo enfrente cuando me
acerco el mira para el costado dije va a
estar difícil elijo al segundo el
segundo me mira y me dice si no me queda
otra dije o ésta se va pues los llevo al
asiento los sentamos visiones calcular
utiliza cuatro tipos de vendas le pongo
las cuatro vendas empezamos con los
trabajos 35 minutos para que el chico
empieza a entrar en estado después de
eso empezamos con las imágenes empieza
con los colores le pongo el rojo beige
amarillo le pongo el azul me dice verde
así seguimos durante un rato hasta que
un momento le pongo el rojo me hice rojo
azul azul verde verde cuando mi señor
device
pero luego más que un sapo no veo tres
sapos y veo el número tres que ganará no
cuesta me agacho quiero ver por las
vendas a ver si estaba mal vendado
estaba perfectamente vendado te pongo
rojo me dice el rojo y veo el número uno
y un auto rojo empiezo a dejar las
imágenes a la distancia más de dos
metros las ve perfectas pero padre le
pido que me acompañe al pizarrón va
cambiando el pizarrón esquiva el escalón
que había adelante agarro un marcador me
pidió que escribamos los números del 1
al 10 a medida que los escribe le voy
borrando algunos y le digo completar me
los y nos empieza a completar a la
perfección te pido que me dibuja una
casa en ese contexto una casa de como un
auto vuelve el auto volvió a la casa y
vuelve a la casa mismo lugar para mí era
como estar adelante un examen no tiene
una explicación me parece increíble este
es el vídeo del segundo día con uno de
los chicos
completando los números que les
comentaba recién
el sistema utiliza cuatro vendas
nosotros ya trabajamos con los mind fall
que es una venda totalmente distinta es
una venda que protege muy bien la vista
una de las cosas más increíbles que pasa
es ver los cambios de chicos después de
esta activación de este despertar de la
capacidad mental que todos tenemos
mejora muchísimo en la escuela mejora
mucho con la elección de los amigos
mejora mucho con la elección de los
adultos pueden percibir si el adulto les
está mintiendo o no pueden percibir si
sus elecciones son correctas o no pero
como bien esto funciona muy parecido un
músculo si nosotros no lo trabajamos
diariamente esto se pierde y se va un
chico que deja de trabajar con esto
durante dos semanas es como que nunca lo
hubiese tenido luego de activar mucho
más rápido pero hay que mantenerlo todos
los días hay que tener la constancia es
muy normal que porque llaman un profesor
diciendo que hicieron con el chico
loción o algún psicólogo que hicieron
está cambiado ayuda a los compañeros
el bullying desaparece por completo es
una de las primeras cosas que se va
otras cosas increíbles es que nos sufren
de depresión y ansiedad y tienen una
guía propia como que saben a dónde
tienen que ir me encuentro con chicos
que parecía que encuentran su vocación
si bien hace tres años estoy con esto
a los 18 muchos ya tienen una especie de
guía cuando se trabajando con los chicos
también se trabaja con los adultos
porque tengo que ver cómo son los padres
y es muy normal que los padres les diga
porque la magia de los miedos de los
chicos son los miedos de los padres
transmitidos a los chicos entonces
normalmente les comento si pudieras
patear el trasero al causante casi todos
tus problemas no te podría sentar
durante un mes el problema más grande es
el miedo de los padres entonces así es
como nace academia córtex acan comodoro
y empiezo a trabajar directamente con
adultos cuando empiezo a trabajar con
ellos muchos me dicen no tengo tiempo
para realizar 15 minutos diarios de
prácticas pero sí es muy normal que
hagan maratones completas los fines de
semana the game for strong o cualquier
otro tipo de capítulos en netflix y se
vean todas las series pero no tienen
tiempo para realizar 15 minutos de
práctica ahora sí hay un montón de
personas que realizan esos cambios mucho
a estas personas normalmente son
personas que mira entre las tres que son
los que tienen la constancia de por eso
todos los días 15 minutos se realizan
las prácticas y con ellos me encuentro
al año me dicen mi vida también por
completo las cosas las veo desde otro
punto de vista ya los problemas no los
veo como problemas los veo como una
solución o como una meta a pasar para
encontrar la solución de forma rápida
y como puede ser que algo tan simple
como despertar esta capacidad mental que
creará nuevas nuevas redes neuronales
pero no tenemos las herramientas para
poder saber cómo lo logra cómo hace la
cabeza porque no tenemos la tecnología
dura tantos cambios en un adulto
y esto es una pregunta que me hacían en
las primeras charlas que di y bien
podemos traer alguna comparación que
pasó con wind of el hombre de hielo
porque muchos no nos conocen pero él
hace 30 años venía diciendo que puede
modificar el sistema inmune a voluntad
el sistema nervioso autónomo del cuerpo
uno lo puede manejar parte a voluntad
todos dijeron que estaba loco 30 años
diciéndolo hace cinco años inyectaron
una bacteria y con su método la mato te
enseño a doce personas más a las doce en
tres días las doce personas del sector
en la bacteria y la matarán no se
enfermaban los otros quedaron todos de
cama una semana enfermos con vómitos
fiebre y diarreas
ahora están agregando una hoja en los
libros de medicina en eeuu the wings of
el hombre de hielo porque esa técnica
permite modificar esa parte del cuerpo
que era autónoma que nosotros no
teníamos alcance y con esto lo mismo
podemos esperar 30 años más a que
tengamos la tecnología para poder saber
qué parte de nuestra mente funciona se
despierta se reactiva y logra tanta
cantidad de cambios o simplemente
probarlo no más que eso me pedían
también que de algún tipo de ejemplo y
más ejemplo que el mío no puedo dar
encontró una especie de equilibrio entre
el amor en la salud la amistad en el
ocio porque podemos tener todo pensamos
que si tenemos trabajo
no podemos tener amigos que si tenemos
amigos no vamos a poder tener bien a
nuestra mujer y es como que unas cosas
encontráis en contra otras y estamos con
nuestros hijos mucho tiempo no estamos
dedicando el tiempo necesario de trabajo
pero podemos encontrar un equilibrio en
todas las áreas y una cosa de las tantas
locas que han pasado en estos últimos
dos años trabajando con chicos y adultos
fue competir con un uno de los adultos
hace seis meses practicando métodos de
memorización y manejo mental
características que te da este tipo de
métodos él se dedicó a aprender sobre
instrumentos de música yo me dediqué a
prender sol pintar cuadros nunca
previamente un cuadro y me intrigaba
aprendí cuatro técnicas la memoriza del
día anterior a la semana tenía seis
cuadros al mes tenía 20 esto fue hace un
poquito más de seis meses hoy tengo más
de 80 y dentro poco de hacer una
exposición porque ya no sé qué hacer con
tantos cuadros no puedo ni colgar las
habilidades que en este tipo de métodos
son increíbles
y lo más increíble es que funciona como
una herramienta más para agregar a
nuestra caja herramientas solucionador
de problemas diarios pero esa
herramienta la podemos utilizar para
cualquier tipo de problema para
cualquier evento preso con una varita de
harry potter nos sirve para todo
tenía que entender es que la causa de
casi todos nuestros problemas que
pasamos gran parte de nuestra vida sin
aprender a utilizar bien nuestra mente
le voy a mostrar un último vídeo de uno
de los chicos cuando pasamos después de
la sexta clase que también se utiliza
con los adultos pero los adultos lleva
mucho más tiempo que es honor de parches
ortopédicos y arriba la máscara porque
los chicos ya de chicos 6 y 8 años están
programados para pensar que es imposible
ver sin utilizarlos los ojos
si este niño se llama luz de buenos
aires
ella se ganó una beca porque no podía
pagar el curso
la unidad y colores
[Música]
no lo sabes
sí
quiere
y esto
[Música]
sí
que está yendo todo con él si bien
es increíble lo que pasa y es increíble
la herramienta que tenemos que todos
tenemos algo que de una forma tan simple
nos puede activar una parte del cerebro
que no estamos utilizando
lamentablemente dedicamos muy poco
tiempo a mejorar nuestros pensamientos
nuestros pensamientos diarios encima en
las escuelas o con charlas con amigos de
esto ni siquiera se habla en
consecuencia pasamos gran parte de
nuestra vida sin saber cómo manejar la
mente al no tener algún mentor que nos
guía de forma clara hacia nuestros
objetivos muchos se distraen se pierden
fracasan y se olvidan y pasan su vida
sin poder encontrar su pasión su misión
algo que los guíe algo que el alma les
está diciendo a dónde tienen que ir
dentro de nuestra cabeza
tenemos el órgano más increíble en el
universo ustedes lo acaban de ver
podemos ver sin utilizar los ojos es
increíble este es el lugar del mundo en
el que estés para poder aprender este
método muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]